well the hottest show in vegas has
arrived rouge is ready to heat up the
stage at the strat and joining us today
is the creator and director hanok rosen
and we also have nicolette over here we
have some incredible performers i can't
wait to see but first off we got to talk
about this show tell us all about it so
it's rouge
uh i would say uh something like
inspiration from 50 shades of grey
meeting meeting crazy horse the paris
you know we have a lot of mail reviews
fantastic melo reviews in vegas female
reviews in vegas but now he's missing a
show that combines
male and female together and we have 20
amazing
cast members like this beautiful girl
and those two handsome guys all talented
top notch in their arctic
artistic knowledge
dancers acrobats
all with
worn prizes and festivals and we're
trying to do it very sexy
very hot
but still very artistic i love it very
artistic we want to do it you know that
to inspire people to bring the fire to
bring uh you know to bring back where
maybe was you know sometimes was lost in
the pandemic we were so depressed and
now it's the time to celebrate our
bodies
and those those guys and girls that are
that are amazing well i i know that
these guys have something really special
planned so while we're talking i say we
kind of get them started so we can get a
taste of what we see at the show those
are the two gladiators they are a
fantasy all the show is built of
fantasies and and one woman has a
fantasy to meet those warriors come back
for more and that's exactly what they're
doing can we show your your power can
you show your power
and are being bathed and then they do
this trick this this exercises of
powerful
muscles
and many times people say is it real do
they really do that this is very real
we are seeing it firsthand
oh i am speechless as i watch this i'm
like should i be nervous but they're
they're professionals they know what
they're doing
we have her as as the empress with all
her maids
and they're looking
can they do that you see
watch his legs and imagine how much
power you have to have in those legs in
order to hold
my god this this weight of his brother
the talent is amazing and i also have to
say the costuming nicolette you look
beautiful in this outfit these are
beautiful is that another element of the
show all huge beautiful costumes very
sexy it's a topless show yeah so the
emperor is looking at these amazing guys
doing that she is you know topless with
all her maids and those girls are are
doing amazing versailles number when
they oh this is good great guys amazing
oh my gosh well thank you guys for
keeping it pg for us but there's
definitely a lot to see at the show
you can you can imagine uh what's there
it's all fantasies uh for example uh
there's one fantasy of uh from the
audience people would say what they want
and one night we had somebody says i
want to have an s m fantasy wow we do it
on stage for him all right so all the
girls with s m with whips and and and
chains and uh
a little bit of everything you guys you
have to check it out rouge will perform
nightly tuesday through sunday at 10 p.m
with an additional show on tuesdays at
8pm inside the strat theater tickets
start at just 49
and you can buy them online at
thestrat.com you must be 18 and over
thank you guys for being here now let's
send it over to